[Music]
it's funny because a lot of people
watching right now grew up watching you
on television you know you started out
you were so young when you're on The
Wonder Years yeah I was 11 years old and
I started on 11 years old I was 11 when
I started this show yeah and right we've
grown up together we've brought together
and you're such an iconic show that your
jacket the jacket that your character
wore that show is in the Smithsonian
Institute it's at the Smithsonian
yeah my mom saved it my mom's garage is
full of I mean also every piece of
memorabilia from me and my my brother
and my sister are Charles her growing up
she has old printers she has nice tons
of stuff in there and we always got a
clean tonight you gotta clean it out and
she had this jacket and this the saurian
wanted it and so now it's in there and
my mom feels like it's this validation
for keeping the garage just full she
should off she should say it my sodium
do you want the rest of it no one want
any of them no one wants it she's like
see yes the only one I'm like they
didn't want that jacket but they don't
want this like you know piece of art
that was on a wall in our house in
Chicago that we still found a place for
I don't know let's check that art out
not so good it's not so good or like a
dot matrix printer I don't know what
maybe I don't know but yeah isn't like
it's it's she's one of them
it's a validation for keeping all this
stuff but we did we went to the
Smithsonian and it was very very very
cool to have been a part of something
that now Cod takes its place you know
next Fonzie's jackets and Dorothy shoes
and yeah well it's a it is it I would
think it is validation for you and and
it was a big deal and you did a smart
thing because a lot of child actors you
know let's face it it doesn't go well
you know I mean it doesn't they're
they're big stars they're on TV and then
there's a motel shootout and and you had
that shootout I remembered but then you
gave up but it was before
yes Graham yeah so really kind of
disappear yeah yeah people you know
periscope did and it was invisible yeah
don't know about your shootout no it
really was luck you did a very smart
thing which is you became a working
television director a hard-working
respected television director much in
demand good for you like you went you
found this career for yourself off
camera but now you're back on cameras
through this interesting perspective oh
it's very
you know it's not a camera and you've
been behind the camera in which way are
you treated better oh for sure on camera
yes it's you made the right call yeah
you are doing it right you've been like
this guy is not getting Hamilton tickets
are you sir
no no way Yeah right we do it's amazing
so I I was good for years I was working
behind the camera and it was great and I
was you know fulfilled and it was
challenging I was I said when you were
directing TV directing TV shows so I was
I was I did this career that built this
career that I wanted to sell right I
imagine having since I was 11 years old
and I was a kid on the Wonder Years I
got married I had a family and it was
just no one really cared at all like I
was just it was just totally off the
grid go to get a restaurant reservation
and you say Oh Savage they don't
remember you from the Wonder you guys
take out all day no seats no seats only
takeout but now on TV you kind of feel
that warm embrace of the love of America
again
and it's really fantastic sounding real
creepy no it's fantastic it's Fanta you
don't know you've been in the embrace no
it's it is different like Annie and I
walk around you know and we were pretty
humble guys but we don't write you know
we don't bust into restaurants and say
we want this place cleared out for us
it's Richter and O'Brien see right I
didn't I didn't I didn't either I didn't
either and then it was gone and now I do
it oh because because you lost it yeah
because she million you know being
humble is great but she really really
doesn't doesn't get you very far so you
come in I'm gonna I'm gonna ride this
thing out man right I'm gonna see this
[Applause]
if you know what it's you know it's fun
to do is this celebrity tell me get a
bit get a sunglasses in a baseball cap
and walk into a restaurant and say are
there any seats and they go like no
we're all full and go are you sure and
then they say no we're sure we're really
sure that we're going to release you
we're going out of business
in fact we're giving up our restaurant
at all
you